[Musique]
salut comment ça va vous allez bien nés
meurent pas la neva rapprochez-vous ok
on est bien aujourd'hui c'est une vidéo
qui est réalisé en partenariat avec f
secure pour parler justement de vous de
votre sécurité de vos données qui sont
exposés aux qui peuvent potentiellement
être exposé sur la toile c'était le cas
pour moi et je vous explique tout ça
fait à tata mais avant toute chose si ce
n'est pas déjà fait vous invite à venir
vous abonner à la chaîne pourquoi pas
c'est effectivement bien aujourd'hui on
parle de cyber sécurité n'ont pas
d'ordinateur de pc deux mc on parle de
tablettes de smartphones on parle
surtout de vous de votre vie numérique
donne des bons conseils et plein de
bonnes intentions ce qu'il faut faire
c'est très simple vous avez le petit
bouton rouge se situe juste ici on sue
vous cliquez vous actionnez la cloche
comme ça vous serez notifié dès qu'une
nouvelle vidéo sortira et ça c'est
vachement bien
en fait ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
il ya quelques jeux dé pékin en un an et
demi devant je sais plus tard rencontre
avec affection dont 7 à 10 des 25 faux
faudrait qu'à l'occasion face au toque
ensemble pour parler de cybersécurité
alors le temps pas si et ça et on se re
contact il ya très peu de temps et m'ont
dit écoute aurélien voudrais présenter
une solution qui s'appelle heidi
protection heidi protection très
franchouillard l'idée de cet outil c'est
de venir d'une voir si vos données ont
été exposés sur internet avec
identifiant et mot de passe et de 2
comment vous protéger et sécuriser votre
compte au travers différents outils donc
ils m'ont dit écoute on a un outil tu le
prends tu laissais en garde cette part
intéressant on peut partir dessus on
peut en parler ok je prends je teste et
qu'est ce qui se passe à travers leurs
outils je vois mes mots de passe de mes
comptes sur internet qui s'affiche sur
mon téléphone entraient dans leur outil
qui prouve
et c'est absolument incroyable que mes
données ont fuité
probablement parce qu'il ya un problème
de sécurité sur un site où j'étais un
script donc mon identifiant et mot de
passe ont circulé sur internet
probablement sur le dark web et si on
fait pas attention si on ne sait pas et
bien moment aurait que certaines
déconvenues et c'est tout l'intérêt de
cette vidéo
ces dunes de vous avertir vous montrer
comment sarraf pour vous puissiez vous
testez de chez vous savoir si vos infos
ont circulé sur internet
et puis 3 vous présenter une solution
intéressante la solution de f secure qui
a vraiment venir vous aider à sécuriser
tout ça est à venir en gros monitorer en
temps réel votre adresse email pour
savoir si vos données sont sur internet
si elles sont corrompus et s'il faut
changer notre
bon la police temps je vais vous montrer
ça vous allez voir truc assez bluffant
je vous montrais sans mon acte si vous
avez un ordinateur près de vous
faites-les mali par un temps que moi
quand je vous mets les liens d'un
description d'un outil qui est gratuit
de notre section c'était vraiment
vraiment impressionnant ce qu'il faut
faire de base ça et sur le site de la
sécu vous avez dans les solutions pour
particuliers il a dans les outils
gratuits vous avez un outil qui
s'appelle f secure identity faible chez
kurt c'est pas si l'accent est bon ou en
tout cas c'est la vérifier si vos
données personnelles ont été exposés
genre comment dire hey perso je le flou
parce qu'il est personnelle ne
comprendraient pas continuer à l'exposé
mais c'est là dessus qu'on va partir
parce que c'est un email que j'ai depuis
très longtemps vérifier les données
dérobées lors ya un petit recaptcha je
clique ok ça marche
vérification en cours 11 suite trouvé
avec email alors je rapporte violations
qui m'a été envoyé par mail et ensuite
il explique qu est ce que je peux faire
changer le mot de passe utilisés
toujours des mots de passe uniques
obtenait elle secure total atteindrait
donc sa solution verte valeur et là ça
devient assez intéressant il faut donc
que j'ai plusieurs sites un premier site
détecte et du mois de juin 2019
s'appelle 80 points comme information
compromise adresse mail non complet nom
d'utilisateur tout va très bien
les combos collecte j'ai tout ça et j'ai
en fait plein de choses
vavi bad ouf badou détecter le dise 2016
badou baddou ben alors bas d'aujourd'hui
c'est un site de rencontre mais à
l'époque où je me suis inscrit il ya
très très très longtemps c'est ainsi
pour mettre cette photo en ligne et où
on partager ses photos pas du tout aussi
de rencontres chez l'écran - c'était pas
si dangereux et myspace ok c'est pareil
voit qu'à mon mot de passe qui a été
récupérée au nom de l'utilisateur
l'adresse email date de naissance il ya
même déjà relativement énorme en termes
d'informations personnelles mais génère
plus de détails si je veux plus de
détails
je peux aller sur mon smartphone ou là
par contre j'ai plein d'autres choses
qui vont s'afficher notamment grâce à
l'application et d'hypothéquer d'alors
et des protections je vais vous montrer
tout à l'heure je vous expliquais mais
ça permettra de vous montrer tous les
détails voir toutes les informations
qu'on fit et c'est quand même
relativement flippant sur mon
application je vais retrouver
sensiblement la même chose alors si j'ai
mis deux adresses email différentes pour
venir surveiller mais c'est sensiblement
la même chose qu'est ce que je vois je
vois que j'ai 13 violations détectés
alors notamment sur canevas points comme
une action une sévérité moyenne dont bon
ya pas trop de quoi s'inquiéter il faut
quand même faire gaffe parce que c'est
ce qu'ils ont récupéré ses moindres à
6000 noms d'utilisateurs et mouvement
complet sera une pratique banale mais si
je vais fouiller par exemple la la j'ai
une
2010neuf anti public combo liste la
débrouille ici toutes les infos ici
c'est une liste combo combine des
données issues de différentes violations
dans une seule et même liste et
disposant ainsi d'identification
personnels dérobés sur plusieurs sources
les sida qui mêle ont plus de chances
entre durant vos contre pour le dire que
ce n'était pas trop rigoler donc là j'ai
mon email
il marque mot de passe il ya les petits
points j'appuie sur l'oeil et là je
tombe sur un mot de passe c'est un
vilain mot de passe mais c'est un mot de
passe que j'utilisais donc f secure ce
qu'ils ont fait c'est qu'en surveillant
la toile notamment le dark web
ils ont récupéré tous ses fichiers que
les pirates utilisent ils ont fait un
lien entre lee mail que j'ai rentré et
limeil lara bien évidemment ils vous
font vérifier votre email faut cliquer
sur le lien peut pas rentrer n'importe
quel email sont également relativement
tranquille là dessus et ensuite ils me
disent ok on connaît ça de vous votre
email et votre mot de passe
et c'est vraiment mon mot de passe et ça
c est que ça c'était un des mots de
passe passe est extrêmement flippant
sources non divulguée et là j'ai deux
mots de passe donc je vois mon vieux mot
de passe et le deuxième mot de passe que
j'avais dit après et et ce truc là en
fait si vous voulez c'est assez flippant
parce que la suisse sur un outil et je
me rends compte qu'en fait est arrivé un
moment où j'étais exposé comme une dinde
en période de noël
c'est extrêmement révélateur des failles
qui peuvent arriver sur internet et
c'est là qu'on se dit ok il faut
vraiment faire attention souvent on
pense que même avec un seul mot de passe
bien sécurisé on est quand même
relativement bon mais si le site se fait
de pirater vous pouvoir le mot de passe
le plus sécurisé du monde il peut poser
des problèmes
alors je sais je sais j'en ai conscience
un constat de base un peu flippant c'est
pas fait pour faire flipper tout le
monde mais c'est une réalité ça veut pas
dire que ça vous est arrivé mais voyez
ça m'est arrivé avec deux comptes ya ce
compte là y'a deuxième conte et
l'histoire de badoo c'est pareil alors
l'email c'est le bon le nom
d'utilisateur c'est pas du tout lien
donc enfin le prêt de l'époque jamais
créé un nom d'utilisateur comme ça donc
je suppose qu'il a été modifié par le
pirate date de naissance 1961 non ce
n'est pas ma date de naissance est
pareil son myspace c'est effectivement
le mot de passe que je m'étais quand
j'étais sur myspace mais il ya quand
même relativement longtemps
même sur ado be alors ado dit système
adresse email c'est un vieil email st
donc voyez on est à l'abri nulle part ça
veut pas dire que ça vous arrive et faut
pas rentrer dans la paranoïa mais il
faut savoir que ça peut exister ce que
je vous conseille quand même c'est venez
utiliser l'outil de f secure et les
gratuits vous permettra de savoir si vos
données ont été compromises
et croyez moi un homme averti en vaut
deux alors maintenant quand les
identifier le problème et bien il faut
peut-être changer quelque chose
d'ailleurs je sais pas si vous vous avez
fait est fait le test et dites moi on
bat en commentaire si vos données ont
été corrompus identifiants mots de passe
pour savoir quel est le mot de passe qui
a été piraté il faut que vous utilisiez
outil heidi protection de f secure c'est
un outil qui est payant mais vous avez
cinq jours gratuits donc cliquer sur un
petit lit en bas vous pouvez venir
l'essayer très facilement vous rentrez
pas de numéro de carte bleue rien vous
avez cinq jours d'essai gratuit
permettra d'avoir toutes les
informations sur le piratage est d'avoir
des premiers conseils après si vous
voulez utiliser par la suite permettra
de monitorer tout ça mais ça je vous
l'expliquais dans quelques instants
en tout cas la première chose à faire à
mon avis c'est de venir modifier vos
mots de passe
ce qui est extrêmement important c'est
d'avoir des mots de passe suffisamment
fort c'est-à-dire différents types de
caractères déjà il faut des lettres
majuscules des lettres minuscules des
chiffres il faut des caractères spéciaux
il faut qu'il soit suffisamment longue
pour ça qu'ils soient pas un mot genre
je m'appelle totaux quelque chose comme
ça et surtout il vous faut un mot de
passe différent par contre vous pouvez
donc soit connaît tous vos mots de passe
et vous en souvenir parker par un
système ou par un autre soit utilisé des
outils qui vont venir gérer vos mots de
passe à votre place et c'est justement
là que l'outil de lecture est
intéressant pour plusieurs raison d'une
pour vous avertir 2 pour vous alerter 3
provost conseiller puis quatrième ans
pour venir gérer vos mots de passe mais
on parle également aussi de numéros de
cartes bleues je vous montre la solution
je trouve intéressante pour l'attester
vous avez cinq jours j'appuie je vous le
dis les liens sont en bas alors regarder
lorsque vous arrivez sur l'accueil bien
vous avez la surveillance un plus petit
radar qui tourne ou en gros c'est que
votre email et monitorer vous avez
jusqu'à cinq adresses emails que vous
pouvez venir suivre donc ça c'est
vraiment rassurant
vous voyez les violations voyez les date
à laquelle elles ont été découvertes
vous avez accès notamment je vous dis à
l'iml vous voyez le mot de passe après
vous avez des actions recommandées en
ressort des conseils qui viennent vous
donnez modifier immédiatement votre mot
de passe dans chaque service qui utilise
le mot de passe ci dessus méfiez-vous
des messages ou des appels indésirables
vous demandant des informations
personnelles relatives de phishing pour
récupérer vos données avant cette
vraiment gaza est activée autant
possible d'identification à deux
facteurs pour vos comptes oncle à vous
avez toute cette liste là et après vous
vous avez vos données à moi par exemple
j'ai ici créer un mot de passe pour mon
compte
f secure est là c'est mon application
qui va elle directement géré mon mot de
passe donc ce qui fait que je peux créer
des mots de passe qui vont être très
fort très long très compliqué quasiment
impossible à mémoriser mais je vais
laisser heidi protection' gérer ça et
16e et mots de passe automatiquement
vous pouvez le mettre sur votre
smartphone ou votre tablette votre
ordinateur vous synchronisez tout ça et
ça marche très bien ensemble
vous pouvez venir à rajouter des données
soit un mot de passe soit une carte
bancaire vous cliquez dessus vous
rentrez toutes vos données titre
titulaire de la carte numéro de la carte
le crypto à l'arrière la date
d'expiration vous mettez la complète moi
ce que je trouve vraiment intéressant
mais cet outil là
c'est déjà de pouvoir savoir quelles
données en fuite et et dès que vous
donnez votre à nouveau corrompu et bien
vous allez être alerté directement et
l'application vous dira quelles sont les
bonnes actions à mettre en place
immédiatement pour dire sécurisé donc ça
c'est cool et je trouve ça vraiment
vraiment vraiment important et une fois
de plus je puis vous assurer que lorsque
j'ai vu ça ça m'a vraiment bluffé
alors je suis content de voir sont pas
mes mots de passe actuelle qui ont été
divulgués mais si c'est arrivé par le
passé ça pourrait potentiellement
arriver à l'avenir donc je pense que
c'est important de changer régulièrement
ses mots de passe est à noter que heidi
protection' est également disponible est
inclus dans f secure total qui a pu
notamment un antivirus et avait png mis
un lien en bas dans la description je
voulais vraiment bien vous sensibiliser
avec ça merci à f-secure d'abord ce
qu'on sorte de cette vidéo de me
permettre de vous parler de ça de vous
expliquer et une fois de plus vite
vraiment à venir faire le test par vous
même et le dire si vous donnez pour être
exposé en bas en commentaire sur ce
point les soins de joie beaucoup d'amour
et à très bientôt
ciao ciao
[Musique]
non